c'est aujourd'hui le jour de la sainte
catherine marie thérèse garcin on va
commencer par le commencement finalement
qui est sainte catherine
alors sainte catherine d'abord le mot
catherine veut dire pureté et descentes
catherine il y en a plusieurs il y en a
d'ailleurs une célèbre en bourgogne
c'est catherine labouré
mais ce qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
dont on l'a fait c'est catherine
d'alexandrie alors catherine
d'alexandrie est né en égypte au
troisième siècle dans une famille plutôt
noble belle éducation très jolie jeune
femme est très érudite el tri quand les
philosophes les poètes et elle va
consacrer sa vie au christ elle se marie
on va dire avec le christ et j'entends
d'ailleurs à ce propos une quête qu'elle
avait refusé d'épouser un malheur
oui exactement l'empereur maximilien
désir l'épousé et après un refus de
refus l'empereur maximilien ne comprends
pas pourquoi
catherine le refuge mais elle est mariée
avec le christ nous pour elle c'est
impossible
donc il va la faire emprisonner et puis
encore une demande de mariage
catherine refuse et là il décide de la
martyrisé il va la mettre sur une île
aval à la ferme être sur une quatre
roues et pour subir le martyre mais là
miracle et quatre roues se disloque et
catherine est sauvé alors là l'empereur
maximilien refait encore une demande
qu'elle refuse et là il décide de la
décapiter alors voilà donc elle meurt le
25 novembre voilà pourquoi on l'a fait
aujourd'hui le l'époque avait pas le 39
et non il vient et où les violences
faites aux femmes et voilà en
iconographie quand on représente
catherine d'alexandrie
que ce soit en peinture en sculpture
elle est toujours représentée avec la
roue puisque quand on voit un saint on
regarde toujours ses attributs pour
savoir à qui on a affaire
et là on voit bien que c'est catherine
d'alexandrie cela dit mes dames anne
ludivine sais pas ce que vous en pensez
moi quand je pense sainte-catherine je
pense tout de suite aux catherinettes
départ mais oui mais oui alors c'est un
avis nettement
qu'est ce que catherine a subi le
martyre
de la roue puisqu'elle n'a pas elle a
refusé d'épouser maximien elle deviendra
la patronne alors de plusieurs
corporations de métiers mais aussi des
jeunes filles qui ont atteint l'âge de
25 ans et une fameuse catherine est et
qu'on appelle des catherinettes
voilà donc une jeune fille qui a atteint
25 ans peut coiffer sainte catherine et
donc ses parents sa famille ça se passe
surtout dans le milieu de la mode est
encore aujourd'hui donc aujourd'hui même
à vesoul
eh bien on va offrir à cette jeune fille
de 25 ans pas mariés un chapeau alors
très extravagant avec qui représente son
métier où sa passion à l'autre jour du
vin jaune et vert c'est obligatoire
versé l'espoir de rencontrer à la
réussite bottes et jaune jaune c'est la
sagesse que cette jeune fille a acquis
au fil des ans
attention parce que la couleur jaune ça
peut prétendre à lyon aussi chantent
pendant les coupes là le message
derrière une autre histoire un soldat 4
a été lassé je vois le divine gérardin
particulièrement attentif sur le chapeau
parce qu'il est très très original le
chapeau des quatre il faut que ce soit
extravagant que ça représente sur
mathieu et représenter son métier où sa
passion
donc ça se fait encore aujourd'hui dont
la mode
dans la mode dans les grands magasins à
paris aujourd'hui on va fêter les
catherinettes
justement vous l'avez évoqué un tout
petit peu on en parlait tout à l'heure
on est en haute saône à vesoul avec une
fête que vous connaissez vos cadets avec
nous si vous êtes dans le secteur
évidemment c'est l'une des plus
anciennes foires médiévales
oui de son histoire avait nommé au
moyen-âge on est dans une région
traversée par les commerçants qui
remonte de du sud de l'europe qui monte
sur le nord de l'europe
alors il ya les célèbres foires de
champagne par exemple la foire de 3 la
foire de provins aussi qui est très
célèbre et chez nous et on a en or à
vesoul et la première fois qu'on va
parler de la foire médiévale de vesoul
il faut remonter à 1295 donc cette année
on fête la 700 24e foire
alors il ya eu quelques interruptions
mais voilà et donc au cours de cette
foire donc toute la ville vit au rythme
de cette journée de la sainte catherine
est alors aussi c'est là les commerces
les agriculteurs les paysans qui ont
fini les travaux des champs viennent
vendre leur surplus de récolte et puis
achète ce qui leur manque
mais aussi c'est l'occasion d'acheter un
cochon à qu'aux qu'ils vont élever
l'hiver qu'ils vont engraisser l'hiver
et l'âge sont mon petit symbole
alors oui mais mais mais c'est une autre
histoire c'est une autre alors c'est un
symbole en fête de la sainte catherine
voyez on met les prénoms de l'acheteur
alors parfois il ya un glaçage chocolat
ou les noirs où on est mon esprit on
n'écrit pardon juste le prénom de la
star mais en fait le pain d'épicés est
un gâteau très anciens oms il nous vient
de chine il ya quelques millénaires on
va vraiment le connaître
au moyen-âge et alors ce qui s'est passé
c'est que ce gâteau ce pain d'épicés
il va on va le mettre faire en cochon et
ça c'est historique en 1131 leroy le
jeune futur roi philippe ii france va se
promène dans les rues de paris à cheval
et là à cochons sûr j'ai le cheval ce
cadre le jeune philippe de france
tombent meurt quelques heures plus tard
et donc le roi de france louis xi sera
en interdire les cochons de errer dans
les rues de paris
sauf les cochons de la billie
saint-antoine et donc pour remercier
cette autorisation des cochons des
moines de saint-antoine de l'habit de
saint-antoine à paris de pouvoir se
promener avec une cloche tour du cou et
bien les moines vont créer ce pain
d'épicés en forme de cochon puisque
saint-antoine est aussi le patron des
chars circulent alors la particularité à
vesoul
allegra c'est le mot voilà donc vous
veulent montrer parce que si on voit il
ya un petit un petit orifice à la plage
à l'emplacement de la queue voilée à
vesoul
on y met un petit sifflet ce circuit est
comme ça une faute l'enfant voilà vous
le voyez le petit sifflet en guise et
une fois que l'enfant samedi au sifflet
voilà à manger le sco sont ok il peut il
peut garder le sifflet et ensuite je me
suis repris ci ne donnait pas le manger
votre cochon